[Musique]
après la levée de l'alerté cyclonique
les séquelles laissées par le passage de
bergues ita sont visibles et profond une
situation qui amène le président du
département à se rendre dans les
communes du sud de l'île
les plus impactés par les vents et les
inondations cyrille melchior mobilise
des moyens supplémentaires pour
intervenir sur les routes
départementales notamment avec une
enveloppe complémentaire de 5 millions
d'euros
la priorité sera de traiter le problème
des radiés et le problème de
l'écoulement des eaux le long des routes
départementales de façon à ce que ces
routes ne soient pas systématiquement
abîmé des forces et en cas d'épisodes
pluvieux comme on a connu avec le
passage bien qu après le tampon saint
pierre cyrille melchior s'est vendu à
saint louis où il a pu constater les
dégâts et apporter son soutien la
population sinistrée
ici les eaux ont emporté toute une
partie de la route là nous sommes
parfois de ravines qui certes n'est pas
départementale mais c'est un confort de
3 rawicz lequel nous travaillons depuis
trois ans avec le département pour avoir
à sion peut pas faire une bascule entre
le pont neuf ce carrefour
puisque c'est la voie naturelle emprunté
par les réunionnais pour se rendre à
pleine débâcle
après un passage sur la commune de
l'étang salé où il a pu faire le point
sur les dégâts et les travaux à venir
il a tenu une réunion avec les
présidents des intercommunalités et les
maires de l'ensemble des communes de
l'île
le président du département présente
l'action de la collectivité dans l'après
berg ita les agriculteurs bénéficieront
d'une aide à la replantation et la
demande de calamité agricole pour
l'ensemble du territoire
le président présente également son
projet de solidarité territoriale
cette solidarité territoriale va elle
prend la forme d'une enveloppe que le
département vin mobilisés à partir de
2018 une enveloppe de près de 20
millions doit accompagner les communes
dans les travaux de proximité des
travaux qui touchent à l'amélioration de
la qualité de vie de nos concitoyens
ces travaux bas les mairies vont nous
dire quelles sont les priorités l'emea
et le que les conseils municipaux vont
définir les priorités et le département
apportera sa contribution dans le
financement de ces projets la visite se
termine dans la commune de saint leu
dans les eaux avec les élus et les
agents des routes mobilisés depuis
plusieurs jours pour rétablir le réseau
[Musique]